my whole life i've been perfect little
meimei if you're not careful you might
just poof into a red panda from the year
it took to design panda may the hours
spent working from home and the creation
of boy band music the challenges were
endless making turning red the team
pulled it off though and happened to be
closer than ever by the end of it how
did they do it let's have a look
it's a little autobiographical this
story
time for a trip to the zoo
that is exactly what the team behind
turning red did the san francisco zoo
let a small group of the creative team
come to the zoo before it opened up to
the public for the day to let them get
up close and personal with some
real-life red pandas red pandas are
usually pretty lazy lucky for them it
was feeding time so the sketch artists
had the chance to draw out their anatomy
and how they moved around the red panda
was really challenging it was to build
in the computer animating it was tricky
but creating this panda based off of the
best source material there was was a
major help and they're such such cute
animals and i feel very fortunate to
have seen them um live this isn't like
any other panda you've seen panda may is
a very chunky panda making her
unbelievably cute even her friends think
so
having such unusual proportions meant
translating the way it moved into the 3d
world while retaining 2d qualities was a
huge hurdle anything naturally anything
with a lot of fur in the computer is
really hard to build and to make it look
just right the most challenging part
figuring out how to make those very
short legs get panda may around in a
natural enough looking way luckily it
was well worth the wait seeing the panda
version of may for the first time was a
special moment for everyone i'm a gross
red monster
[Applause]
if the tech doesn't exist why not invent
it a brand new technology was developed
and introduced for turning red to make
sure there was diversity throughout the
program would scan frames from the
different scenes to see what the
representation was like if the image
didn't meet the mark and really
reflecting the world we're living in
then the animating team would go back in
and make the adjustments needed
this diversifying included all the
details you could think of from small
ones like having a character that used
an insulin pump and including wheelchair
accessible ramps outside the temple it's
time to meet your new favorite boy band
the musical minds behind four town none
other than billy eilish and phineas
o'connell producer lindsay collins was
keen to get the two artists to sign on
to the movie so she went full fangirl
and made a scrapbook that mae would have
made full of four town pictures and
drawings including the faces of billy
and phineas on top collins wasn't really
sure they'd be into it but the duo was
open to a meeting with a creative team
and the deal was sealed we have three
songs in the in the movie that are
original four town songs the fact that
the musicians happen to be huge
animation fans helped phineas even lent
his sweet voice to the four town member
jessie boy bands it's the really catchy
melody and harmonies and claps and
choreography time for voice over magic
with all the recording happening during
the pandemic the performers were far
more isolated than usual sometimes they
were even halfway around the world pop
singer anne-marie recorded her cameo as
lauren from the uk with domici directing
her virtually that was so weird for me i
loved it though when the band had to get
together to nail those sweet sweet
harmonies they had to get a bit creative
with the booth you can't have a story
about a 13 year old girl without having
a boy band each performer had their own
hut built featuring windows all within
one studio so they could record on their
own but together it was all loads of fun
how many jokes did we miss
turning red is full of laugh-inducing
moments and while a lot of the jokes
wound up on the cutting room floor one
in particular came pretty close to
making the final cut it was when she's
like talking about they're talking about
the boys on the track and they're
sitting in the bleach oh yeah just how
corny was this joke well it speaks for
itself the joke was
are you a beaver cause damn
fingers crossed it'll end up in the
bonus features
caution the following images may induce
drooling how much do we want to eat all
the food we see on screen the secret to
making it look so appetizing was
somewhat surprising though food needs to
be oily
look oily and glossy in order for it to
feel delicious other drool inducing
details included making sure the colors
of the food were very vibrant and
saturated with just the right amount of
oily gloss
domici had a crystal clear vision from
the very beginning my biggest
cultural and artistic
inspirations and influences are like
disney and pixar and japanese anime the
liquid in water was styled in the same
way it is in anime with a kind of thick
and glue-like quality to it streaky
style light on windows was another nod
and of course the oh so expressive eyes
that allowed the animators to push the
character's emotion in a kind of
exaggerated way but perfectly in line
with the vibe of the movie 2d or 3d
or both
the animation in turning red is unlike
any other pixar movie we've seen and yet
it's still somehow familiar i think from
the beginning we really wanted to push
the style of this movie the team's goal
was a combination of the 2d and 3d world
not an easy ask with animators who've
been used to working and designing in a
certain way for a number of years did
ask the animators to go out of their
comfort zone supervising animator patty
kim was pretty nervous going into it
unsure the unique style domi had wanted
from the very beginning would actually
work out we were trying to figure out a
way to get the essence of 2d in a 3d
world eventually a balance was found and
used as a tool in the movie just when we
thought we couldn't love disney pixar
anymore working on a project this big
with a team virtually in the middle of a
pandemic can become stressful but the
vfx supervisor daniel feinberg wasn't
going to let that get the team down so
she created this thing called the power
panda poof uh weekly nominations every
single week different cast and crew
members would write kind things about
their co-workers spreading the love so
that during their crew tea time emails
could be read aloud for everyone to hear
could there be a more uplifting and
sweet event
everybody get cozy
i mean four years i've been working on
this film for four years and two of
those years involved working almost
exclusively remotely i mean we worked on
it for quite a while and for much of
that time we were in our homes turning
red was in pre-production for animation
when everything shut down a couple of
weeks later everyone was ready to go
full steam ahead set up to work from
home even if it wasn't always ideal we
made them the film from home
uh in our in our guest rooms on our
kitchen tables right what you know after
all
while domici never turned into a red
panda when she was growing up a whole
lot of other details in the movie were
drawn from her real life and the place
she grew up toronto so much of it you
can just trace it back to exactly like
her relationship with her mom and her
growing up even characters like each of
the girls in mae's close circle of
friends were based on a friend that she
had in her life at some point
at some points all the characters were a
bit uptight panda may took advantage of
that when she needed stacy to get out of
her way after working a certain way for
years the animators were reminded to
explore the options no no forget all of
that now let's try something totally
different don't move the body the team
took a chance on a special technology
called profile movers developed by bill
sheffler the tech could calculate
smaller movements and take care of
miniscule articulation points in a
character's bodies so the artists could
focus on the bigger picture and much to
their delight it worked like a charm
that was really cool welcome to turning
red aka the color palette of our dreams
that rona spent a lot of time thinking
about color on this film we've got may
and fire red and ming in the opposite
emerald green each of may's gal pals got
their own color based on their vibes as
well who runs the world girls
turning red marks the first pixar film
to have an all-female team in the
creative leadership roles
and it kind of happened by accident
there was a focus to put a team together
that would work well and this group of
women proved that they really did they
happened to work the most efficiently of
any pixar film in history only taking
about four years to create this movie
from scratch which is pretty short for
pixar
disney pixar has done it again
turning red brings the best of the
classic way of working to the newest
technologies which part of making the
movie do you think would have been most
challenging